[Applaudissements]
chaque jour la télévision nous fait
découvrir des petits génies et c'est une
séquence que vous attendez on en parle
énormément ou une fois n'est pas coutume
on va commencer avec les marseillais
contre le reste du monde et oui on va
s'intéresser plus précisément à la
marseillaise qui s'appelle maeva maiva
très fallait beaucoup parce que c'est la
fille qui n'a peur de rien elle n'a pas
peur des fantômes
elle n'a pas peur des serpents elle n'a
pas peur du vide à la peur juste d'un
truc
les flambées regarder une idée
et attend
c'est une mauvaise réponse par là
[Applaudissements]
c'est une mauvaise réponse maeva alors
mais ça c'est exceptionnel
franchement alors forcément après cette
scène de panique la production a demandé
à maeva pourquoi elle avait peur des
flambées et quand elle donne son
explication forcément moi là je me suis
là franchement mea culpa c'est qu'on
prend c'est bon excuse moi mais il a
essuyé la somme des gouttes c'est pas
humain
moi les seuls humains que je peux
toucher c'est les chiens les chats et
les humains
alors on a découvert comme albanais mais
pas des desserts en revanche il ya un
truc qu'elle adore c'est l'anglais maeva
je peux vous dire elle est plus que
bilingue elle est au delà de bilan
regarde là bas
non look look je prends mon chocolat du
tricheur l'autre look my bush please
il goûte cheese me chimie gouda lui il
not good and the cat hamouda en tout bas
il est bilingue
moi je suis à l'aise je comprends rien
[Musique]
[Rires]
je me dis c'est pas possible il faisait
un concours ils se disent celui qui fait
le plus dans les dents les dans les best
of dans les cibles des victimes alors
quand ils sont pas sur w9 les cerveaux
se déplace sur tf1 dans la bataille des
couples ça fait déjà plusieurs semaines
que les candidats sur sur une île
déserte
visiblement le soleil commence à
réchauffer les affaires où je vous le
dis fini les gestes tendres fini les
bisous dans le cou et finis les petits
câlins qu'aucun même valérie benaïm et
patoche ont plus de chances de passer
noël ensemble nos amis tf1 regardez
[Musique]
comme papa c'est une foule quoi sans toi
aussi
pour faire ses pâques c'est le vent qui
pourrait souffler à temps mais c'est
vraiment à l'égoïsme
[Musique]
jamais de mal à retenir il a le droit je
te dis
astana je voudrais parler du coup
vincent et mélanie alors le pauvre
vincent
il n'en peut plus de sa meuf parce
qu'elle n'arrête pas de crier il avait
déjà perdu son tympan droit jeudi
dernier eh ben ce week end
ça y est les deux sont touchés regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
disons qu elle alors les chéris
maintenant on va parler des génies
d'autres génies et là c'était dans 90
minutes enquête je peux vous dire c'est
le meilleurs extraits depuis très très
longtemps
on est tombé sur une intervention très
très dangereuse de la police nationale
savez quand on bosse dans la police sait
jamais pourquoi on va être appelé c'est
peut être un braquage de banque
ça peut être un vol de viette de
voitures où ça peut être bien bien pires
s'est passé sur 90 minutes enquête et je
peux vous dire moi franchement je
n'étais pas bien j'ai vu ça
regardez les images regarde une pizzeria
pour laquelle il a reçu une plainte d'un
client dans c'est une personne qui a
commandé
une pizza quatre fromages et qui au
final n'en avec 3 sur sa pizza
donc bon bah c'est vrai que si la
personnes s'attendaient à avoir une vie
à 80 il faut qu'un et 4 dessus donc on
va aller regarder ça et en profiter pour
faire un contrôle complet c'est du bluff
mesure cm et sachez qu'on vous a pas
montré la suite sachez que après le gars
renvoyé le logis viennent parce qu'un
gars des glycines bergese dans un
couscous fait comme ça a été
l'escaladent de l'horaire cervélo ça
y'est là que je sais pas tu fais le
reportage c'est le caméraman thaïlandais
ji [ __ ] je pense est tombé sur le mac
est arrivé à la vie d'un village
comptait les fromages à lorient n'a
alors rien du comté c'est bon il ya du
roquefort et il ya du chèvre il manque
un fromage monsieur je suis d'accord
avec la police la ta merde top est sûre
et d'avenir que le gars cool c'est
autant j'ai parce que j'ai pas suivi
c'est un policier parce qu'il a commandé
une pizza quatre fromages et sage et là
je suis mais je n'ai pas vu que je ne
sais pas si c'était un point suivant
l'intervention de québec peut-être
s'arrêter là pourquoi mais le policier
se déplace alors des fois les policiers
tuent les abeilles avaient du temps la
menace et les bus arrivent et le
gyrophare opus il ya 1200 non non non
non c'est assez dire enfin c'est un
morceau fromage merci
on a aussi des génies qui sont sur les
plateaux des jeux télé dans slam sur
france 3 on est tombé sur un candidat
qui nous a fait beaucoup de peine
il vient de gagner la partie le mec qui
est hyper fier il veut faire un check à
cyril féraud l'animateur qu'on embrasse
mais l'animateur et ben il lui colle le
vent du siècle là c'est un vent vraiment
la sienne rafale eco89
regardez bravo finition vannes ce que
c'était c'était des lacets sur place là
bas voilà ses fils et sa bru ici
regarder les scores à battre en trois
points et les secours vers 33 points je
vis dans slam c'est une candidate qui
est venue accompagnée de son fils pierre
il assis dans le public bien et vous
allez voir que pierre il a un physique
de premier de la classe
mais attention le gage pour rien quand
il est énervé et clash aussi fort qu
eric naulleau regarde je suis content
t'asseoir gens
merci changer les chéris bah oui c'est
l'autre c'est avant ça sera après on en
direct à finances publiques on m'a dit
ah oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que toute
la famille travail aux impôts
yakhi alors il ya votre mari ya qui
d'autre il y avait mon papa d'accord
ma belle-mère pierre est ce que ça te
dirait travail et aux impôts alors pas
du tout parce que je profite de l'argent
aux gens la pire insulte on l'a trouvé
dans plus belle la vie vous avez eu un
petit teaser grâce à l'équipe technique
est ce que vous connaissez théo belle
alors c'est un des personnages de plus
belle la vie et théo malheureusement il
s'est embrouillé en classe d âge peuvent
rien en plus belle la vie c'était chaud
chaud chaud bouillant quoi lâcher
tu compte asseoir gens
alors des eaux va découvrir une insulte
qui a été taguée sur sa table connaissez
france télévisions c'est familial c'est
bienveillant donc petit jeu l'insultent
sur théo bommel sera bommel but des
pieds bommel crottes de nez aux baumes
elles sont le pipi à la drass et c'est
trop violent
et bien c'est aucune des trois c aucune
des trois et sachez que c'est passé sur
france télévisions j'étais chaud les
bâlois pas loin de ta mère regardez
[Musique]
c'est du vrai beau belle va suscita
soeur écoulée anatomy qui n'a aucun sens
en plus techniques déjà rentré dans les
détails c'est bon bah oui merci c'est
bon